Let's pick up from where we left off with our last demo,
with the larger grocery store dataset this time.
At the end of the last demo,
we had each query complete but not yet loaded or connected.
We also went through and we disabled loads for any of the queries that are
intermediary queries that we don't want showing up for
the reporting pane or the modeling pane.
Let's go ahead and close and load.
Now, having closed the Power Query,
we have our data loaded and we have
a date table that we very carefully set up in the prior lesson.
Let's go ahead and go to our data pane or view as you may refer to it.
I'm going to select this and I'm going to select mark as date table.
Now, note right here that because I have,
although date-time turned on,
it's giving me a little hierarchy that I could use if I wanted to,
but since we have a dedicated date table instead,
I'm going to make this our explicit date tables so we have more control.
Going to select "Date" as our date column.
Again, it is validated successfully.
We'll go ahead and click this.
As you can see right here,
it gives you a little note that says the built-in date tables,
that's this date hierarchy right here,
are going to be removed,
which is exactly what we want.
Now, this is set with a little icon here that
allows us to know that this is our designated date column and we're good to go.
Let's go back to our model view.
Just like we did with the smaller dataset,
we're going to be creating relationships from our customer dimension,
product dimension, and date dimension to connect to our sales transactions.
The way that we'll do that is either by dragging and connecting to our customer ID.
So our two keys are connected.
Or by going up to manage relationships,
selecting new, and choosing each of our dimensions in turn,
and connecting them to our sales transactions.
Now, here we have a one-to-one relationship.
Power BI is assuming that we want a one-to-one relationship here,
and it's assuming wrong.
Let's go ahead and select many-to-one or rather one-to-many,
because many-to-one would suggest that the date dimension has many sales has one-to-many.
Cross filter direction we're going to make single.
We're going to make this relationship active.
Let's try other detecting for the third and see how Power BI does.
Found one new relationship.
Let's select "Edit" and see what it shows for us.
Sales transaction product ID,
product data, product ID,
many dimension on the sales side,
one dimension on the product side,
cross filter direction is single.
It's gotten this one right.
Auto detect is a good option as a starting point,
but I would encourage you to never just use auto detect without
first checking because as we saw with this second relationship for date,
Power BI sometimes guesses wrong, and sometimes spectacularly.
There we have our three-dimensions.
Now, what would happen if I needed to change these for any reason?
Well, one, I can always hover over them to see what the relationships are,
and I can double-click and I can edit the relationship accordingly.
Now, if hypothetically, I had named this very wrongly,
and preferred store was meant to be my relationship,
you can set up a relationship by adjusting it.
If I wanted to use many-to-many,
which of course I do not.
As you can see, it will allow me to create a relationship that is completely wrong.
There is no relationship between these two except through the Customer ID,
but as you can see,
it gives you a lot of flexibility to choose that nonetheless.
Last thing we should talk about is the cross filter direction.
Most of the time we want single,
but if we need both,
we can select it here.
Here we have three one-to-many relationships
going from the dimension to our fact table.
This is a tiny star telling you that there are many relationships in place.